[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le mardi 23 mars tout de
suite les titres de cette édition
il doit voir le jour en 2024 à saint
quentin en yvelines le futur
commissariat d'agglomération entre dans
une nouvelle phase à elancourt avec les
appels d'offres le site concentrera
l'horizon 2024 l'activité de 300
policiers basés aujourd'hui à elancourt
lui en cours et rap
les agents des polices municipales
sensibilisés à la question des violences
conjugales des journées de formation
sont proposées conjointement par la
police nationale et la gendarmerie des
yvelines
l'objectif comprendre le mécanisme de
l'emprise mentale du stress
post-traumatique mais aussi apprendre à
mieux réagir sur le terrain
et puis c'est en cours d'expérimentation
à montigny le bretonneux un centre de
chirurgie dédié à la main pour faire des
opérations en peu de temps il a été
lancé en juin 2020 par deux médecins en
collaboration avec l'agencé régionale de
santé l'hôpital de rambouillet nous en
parlons avec nos invités
présentation également en tout à l'heure
du deuxième id job dating qui se tient à
saint quentin en yvelines ce jeudi 7 en
ligne un événement spécial dédié à
l'alternance
[Musique]
mais je vous le disais dans les titres
le projet de commissariats
d'agglomération à elancourt entre dans
une phase d'administration ministre
hâtive avec les appels d'offres du côté
du ministère de l'intérieur et de la
police nationale des yvelines les
réflexions sont en cours pour voir les
technologies qui vont intégrer ce nouvel
édifice estimé à plus de 20 millions
d'euros nicolas landry c'est ici en 2024
que le commissariat d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines verra le jour
à la place du complexe de tennis
d'elancourt cet établissement
centralisera l'activité des 300
policiers des commissariats d'elancourt
de guyancourt et de trappes tout en
conservant une présence dans chaque
commune ce nouveau commissariat nous
permettra d'une meilleure coordination
dans le travail
une organisation plus efficiente au sein
de nos unités une meilleure coordination
de travail notamment entre les unités de
voie publique et les différents services
d'investigation qui sont amenés à
travailler bien évidemment ensemble des
groupes de travail rassemblant des
équipes du ministère de l'intérieur font
régulièrement des réunions
objectif déterminer les besoins des
futurs membres du commissariat
d'agglomération d'elancourt c'est un
commissariat innovant puisque il doit
servir à améliorer les relations police
population mais également les relations
police partenaire de la police nationale
et améliorer également la qualité de vie
au travail des fonctionnaires de police
notamment par l'ensemble de ces
innovations technologiques des
équipements technologiques avec un
développement du numérique dans
l'activité des policiers
on pourrait imaginer aussi l'utilisation
de drones une perspective favorisée par
le tissu économique dans le secteur de
la défense sur le territoire beaucoup
d'entreprises travaillent sur sur ce ce
cette stratégie d'améliorer la sécurité
des français
c'est vraiment la sécurité demain du
futur voilà donc c'est ce sera le ca va
être certainement un des prototypes un
des modèles de la sécurité de demain en
france
ce projet est le fruit d'une
collaboration entre l'état la région le
département et saint quentin en yvelines
l'investissement est estimé à 20
millions d'euros dans les prochaines
semaines l'architecte sera choisi
la livraison est prévue fin 2023 début
2000 24 mètres des violentes au m sur
les sachets des baguettes de pain c'est
à l'initiative du collectif féministe
nous tout une grande collecte nationale
a permis d'étendre l'opération à toute
la france hier mardi et hier lundi
l'antenne yvelinoise accompagné de la
mairie de trappes a organisé une
distribution dans une boulangerie du
quartier des merisiers 5000 sachets ont
été remis dans neuf boulangerie de la
commune le violente au maître est un
outil qui permet avec une série de
questions graduée d'évaluer la violence
au sein de son couple et de trouver tous
les numéros aude écoute et d'urgence les
propos recueillis par nicolas landry
c'est plus de 600000 emballages qui vont
être distribués dans toute la france
par plus de 3000 militante qui ont
contacté les boulangeries de leurs
quartiers dans les yvelines
il ya 60 points tri qui vont nous aider
on a dû ce limité parce qu'on n'avait
pas suffisamment de l'emballage et
heureusement ils avaient mairie qui nous
accompagne également qui ont fait
imprimer de leur côté des emballages
pour leurs conneries
nous avons distribué ses sacs ses cinq
as pas dans toutes les boulangeries de
trappes
nous avons déjà fait une première
rencontre en vue d'expliquer quelle
était la démarche et toutes ont adhéré
lors du 2ème confinement novembre les
signalement pour violences conjugales
ont augmenté de 60%
la hausse était de 40% lors du premier
confinement toujours autour de cette
thématique des violences conjugales la
police nationale et la gendarmerie des
yvelines propose aux policiers
municipaux sur la base du volontariat et
des journées de sensibilisation le but
étant de faire comprendre le mécanisme
de l'emprise mentale du stress
post-traumatique mais aussi apprendre à
mieux réagir sur le terrain le reportage
d'astrid bergère 90 féminicide ont eu
lieu en 2020 146 en 2019 dans les
yvelines les policiers et gendarmes sont
mobilisés pour mieux accueillir et
orienter les victimes de violences
conjugales
il propose des journées de
sensibilisation cette journée
sensibilisation elle s'adresse aux
policiers municipaux
du département des yvelines sur la base
du volontariat bien évidemment ça permet
de leur faire comprendre ce que sont les
violences conjugales
le mécanisme et surtout leur donner des
outils derrière pour mieux accueillir
les victimes de violence organisée
conjointement par la police la
gendarmerie et la préfecture ces
formations sont nécessaires c'est
indispensable parce que nos collègues
des prix ce municipales sont souvent
confrontés avant nous j'ai envie de dire
avant le dépôt de plaintes par exemple à
ses victimes
donc il faut absolument qu'ils
comprennent ce qui est une victime
comment elle peut être amenée à réagir
et comment on l'accueille et comment on
oriente la journée se déroule en trois
temps
la matinée est consacrée à la
connaissance de ce qu'est l'emprise
mentale et le stress post traumatique
ensuite les policiers apprennent à mieux
réagir sur le terrain l après-midi un
échange avec une association est
organisé et les policiers municipaux
sont très demandeurs pense que c'est
important il faut te il faut être prêt à
telle écoute sur toutes les différentes
missions et dont ses missions où il ya
une méconnaissance
je pense à des forces de l'ordre pas
avoir par rapport à tout ça et surtout
d'état l'écoutent par rapport à ces
problèmes
d'après l'audit sur l'accueil en
commissariats et brigades de gendarmerie
des victimes de violence 90% des
victimes s'est dit satisfaite de
l'accueil des résultats encourageants
mais qui peuvent être améliorées et
puisse de s'améliora sion ces deux
formes et former informer de manière à
ce que tous nos collègues qu'ils soient
police/gendarmerie municipale etc
connaissent ce phénomène ce phénomène et
les particularités de ce phénomène et
toutes les personnes qui travaillent en
police municipale dans les yvelines
peuvent participer à ces journées de
sensibilisation dans l'actualité les
chiffres du colis de 10 900 vols en ile
de france d'après les dernières données
de la rs le taux d'incidence s'établit
désormais à 549 pour 100000 habitants
dans la région selon coe vitrac heures
soit deux fois plus que le seuil
d'alerté fixé à 250 par le gouvernement
qui a placé le territoire francilien
comme huit autres départements français
en confinement pour quatre semaines
minimum est la tendance dépasse donc
désormais celle observée lors de la
deuxième vague en octobre avec un taux
d'incidence qui avait a grimpé jusqu'à
543 en ile de france
par ailleurs on apprend aujourd'hui
qu'en raison d'un cluster avéré au
collège jacques cartier aïssou
l'établissement est fermé jusqu'à ce
vendredi au moins est la décision a été
prise ce mardi en accord avec la
direction académique des yvelines et
j'accueille en plateau un une invit
elisabeth calment bonsoir vous êtes la
directrice du centre hospitalier de
rambouillet 12 ans et de l'ehpad d'ablis
vous êtes venu sur ce plateau pour
parler d'un autre sujet que le colis 19
tout de même une première question sur
la situation dans le sud yvelines quelle
est la situation
on apprend aujourd'hui ce chiffre que au
niveau francilien il s'agit pas de la
situation locale moniot francine à 80%
des opérations vont être désormais des
programmes en ile-de-france pour libérer
déplaçant en réanimation dans le sud
yvelines qu'elle est là la situation
alors ça vous convient effectivement
qu'il ya une tension qui est extrêmement
forte sur les vies de soins critiques et
soit critique ce sont les lits de
réanimation et les lits de soins
continus qui nécessite un personnel tout
particulièrement former une densité
aussi plus importante
danser dans ces catégories de prise en
charge
donc effectivement la tension est très
très forte également à rambouillet et on
voit que nous sommes de plus en plus
appelés pour accueillir des patients y
compris des patients jeunes main
d'ailleurs c'est important à signaler ce
n'est pas uniquement les personnes les
plus âgées qui sont victimes de l'aco
vide et qui ont besoin d'hospitalisation
soins critiques
nous avons dernièrement une
hospitalisation d'un passion de 35 ans
donc ça il faut aussi bien avoir un
esprit chaleureux à soul humant
absolument en visioconférence avec nous
également un autre invité c'est le
docteur françois bruche ou bonsoir
bonsoir vous est le cofondateur du
centre de chirurgie externe dédié à la
main yvelines sud alors vous êtes venus
tous les deux dans ce journal pour nous
parler justement de cette innovation
dans le monde médical en france un
centre de chirurgie externe qui est en
cours d'expérimentation à montigny le
bretonneux et ce depuis juin 2020 une
structure dédiée à la main pour faire
des opérations en peu de temps le
patient reste également sur place
seulement quelques heures les
explications dans ce reportage de
nicolas d'ombrie se faire opérer de la
main comme quand on va chez le dentiste
c'est l'innovation proposée par le
centre de chirurgie externe dédié à la
main yvelines sud
cette structure en expérimentation
située à montigny le bretonneux a été
lancée en juin 2020 par les docteurs
christian couturier
et françois bruche où on a constaté que
beaucoup d'interventions en chirurgie de
la main pouvait se faire avec des
anesthésies beaucoup plus légère que ce
que l'on fait habituellement avec un
circuit beaucoup plus court et que
l'hospitalisation n'était pas nécessaire
on fait des interventions exactement les
mêmes conditions de sécurité avec la
même technicité que dans un bloc
opératoire
cette innovation s'inspire du modèle
anglo saxon appelée office surgery le
patient reste peu de temps dans la
structure il vient et repart du centre
comme si c'était une consultation
médicale
toutes les pathologies de la main ne
sont pas concernés alors on opère le
canal carpien les doigts arceaux les
tendinites de carvin les petites tumeurs
les kystes les maladies dupuytren simple
les tendinites par exemple où coulent
les épicondylite on peut libérer des
nerfs superficielle quand ils sont
coincés à l'avant bras ou autour du
coude
cette pratique chirurgicale est rendu
possible grâce à une technique
d'anesthésié locale
la méthode wallon c'est finalement une
anesthésie locale avec des produits
vasoconstricteur ce qui fait qu'on n'a
pas besoin de garons pour faire la
chirurgie le produit vasoconstricteur
fait un garrot chimiques et empêche le
saignement pendant l'opération
au programme de cette matinée un
syndrome du canal carpien ou encore le
déblocage d'une main on a le nerf médian
qui est coincé dans un petit tunnel qui
s'appelle le canal carpien à l'entrée de
la main et donc on va couper ce ligament
pour écarter les berges du ligament et
donner de la place aux nerfs qui a
écrasé route
tendez la main allez-y pays à fond et
voilà
oui on a le résultat immédiat ses gonds
quand même gros intérêt de cette méthode
vous ce centre de chirurgie externe est
développé en collaboration avec l'agencé
régionale de santé d'île de france
il bénéficie d'un support technique
provenant de l'hôpital de rambouillet de
nouveaux outils devraient venir
compléter le projet comme un masque de
réalité virtuelle donner aux patients
pendant l'opération aux côtés du docteur
christian couturier que vous avez vues
dans ce reportage françois bruchot
docteur rossi qui a cofondé ce centre on
disait françois bruchot un centre
innovant l'innovation finalement c'est
que tout se fait très vite sur place le
sujet à 10
allait se faire opérer de la main un peu
comme si on allait chez le dentiste ça
ça n'existe pas encore en france
c'est une innovation c'est quelque chose
qui se met progressivement en place en
plusieurs centres existent déjà en
france mais c'est le premier centre où
on a une vraie salle d'opération
exactement comme dans un bloc opératoire
donc c'était une véritable innovation où
on peut faire des techniques avec de la
nano endoscopie des techniques qui est
extrêmement innovante et et ceci bien
sûr grâce avec à la collaboration que
l'on que l'on met en place avec
l'hôpital de rambouillet pour tous les
services et les techniques et les led
notamment en stérilisation d' équipe
opérationnelle d'hygiène le soutien
technique et puis les transferts aux
conventions de patients au cas où il ya
même il faut toujours avoir une
convention ce qu'il n'y avait qu'un
hôpital et c'est extrêmement intéressant
de pouvoir créer cette collaboration
privé public
c'est un petit peu la grèce nous à nous
a poussés à dans ce sens et les madame
calmons nous a accueillis c'était un
grand plaisir
on va parler un peu plus avec justement
il y avait de calmants de ce partenariat
avec l'hôpital de rambouillet on le
disait une expérimentation lancée depuis
juin 2020 est ce que il ya déjà un
premier bilan à faire quel est le
premier bilan que vous pouvez faire de
ces presque un an maintenant de
fonctionnement n'est pas encore un an
mais on y arrive petit à petit bah
écoutez c'est c'est le retour des
patients est assez fantastique c'est
quelque chose qui est qui leur octroie
une simplicité de fonctionnement
c'est exactement comme vous l'avez
expliqué dans votre votre reportage
comme lorsque l'on va chez le dentiste
c'est aussi simple que cela
les gens n'ont pas besoin d'être à jeun
bien sûr on exclut toutes les
pathologies coronariennes et personnes
avec certainement âgées qui peuvent
nécessiter un suivi il ya une prise en
charge un petit peu plus personnalisés
mais pour toute la majorité des gens
c'est quelque chose qui est extrêmement
simple il ya la consultation anesthésie
il n'y a pas de pré mission les gens
arrivent se sont opérés et repartent par
eux mêmes comme comme chez le dentiste
donc c'est une
c'est un un retour une satisfaction
extrêmement rare et extrêmement
étonnante mais vous le dis avec un
partenariat avec la rs l' agence
régionale de santé et l'hôpital de
rambouillet il avait également vous en
est la directrice tout comme l'hôpital
de 12 ans et l'ehpad dhabi
l'établissement fournit un support
technique le docteur rush ou en parlait
ce sens alors effectivement
l'établissement propose a ouvert son
bloc opératoire au docteur bruce jouer
au docteur couturier et à leurs équipes
nous ça a été vraiment une très très
belle opportunité que d'être approché
par une équipe qui est très
honorablement connue dans le secteur de
la santé et qui est une reconnaissance
également du travail qui peut se faire à
l'hôpital de rambouillet donc nous
ouvrons le bloc opératoire ce qui veut
dire que nous mettons à disposition
d'une équipe d'anesthésistes nous
mettons à disposition des infirmières
anesthésistes des infirmières de bloc
opératoire des techniques également
développé par les anesthésistes comme
par exemple la prise en charge du stress
péri opératoire nous mettons également à
disposition l'organisation de notre
chirurgie ambulatoire
nous mettons à notre à disposition
également l'équipe opérationnelle
d'hygiène qui a pu déjà visité le centre
de montigny et proposer quelques
recommandations d'aménagement du centre
et puis nous mettons également à
disposition notre notre stérilisation
puisque le centre de montigny donne sens
et les équipements à stériliser dans
notre établissement donc c'est vraiment
une chance et puis une chance également
pour le la population du sud 10 lignes
d'être prise en charge vraiment au plus
près de leur domicile
je suis à ce groupement hospitalier du
territoire insu dont fait partie le
talent de rambouillet du coup mettre à
disposition à bloc opératoire c'est à
dire que sur place on peut faire des
opérations peut être plus lourde que
celle réalisée à montigny
voilà les interventions que qui
nécessitent un environnement de bloc
opératoire plus plus important que celui
qui est déployé à montigny donc c'est
c'est l'idéal parce que nous complétons
parfaitement bien c'est la meilleure des
meilleures des postulats pour pour tout
mariage en fait autant bouche ou parler
du partenariat dans ce domaine de la
santé entre établissements privés
établissements publics
c'est important ça fait sens surtout
peut-être en cette période
en ce moment de crise sanitaire oui je
pense que le les compétences médicales
soignantes sont trop précieuse pour les
gaspiller et quelle que soit l'origine
conçoit structures publiques aux
structures privées
il faut vraiment qu'on puisse travailler
ensemble parce que nous nous complétons
vraiment très bien pour mettre à
disposition les compétences justement
qui sont de plus en plus rare quand même
pour que la population puisse être prise
en charge le mieux possible et c'est ce
que nous nous employons à faire à
travers ce partenariat dr bruchot vous
le disiez tout à l'heure le ce
partenariat oui entre le privé et le
public c'est quelque chose de primordial
aussi à vos yeux
oui c'est quelque chose d'important bien
sûr et tout c'est le développement avec
christian couturier on a développé le
centre urgence main à l'hôpital trier
l'ouest parisien
et là c'est le sait c'est l'occasion de
pouvoir développer un autre centre
d'urgences de la main sur rambouillet où
les gens sont très bien sûr aux tarifs
opposables et s'éteint c'est quelque
chose qui qui qui nous tient à coeur
bien sûr cette collaboration prix du
public et ses visions de ses missions de
service public
on a toujours fait depuis notre notre
internat toute dernière question on est
dans une phase d'expérimentation du coup
la prochaine étape
quelle est elle la prochaine étape c'est
là c'est la reconnaissance par là il
reste est peut-être à ce moment là une
aide de la rs&de fin des anges jointe à
la sécurité sociale pour développer ce
type de centre qui coûte beaucoup moins
cher
bien sûr qu'une hospitalisation dans un
an une structure privée ou dans un
hôpital public donc pour toute la petite
chirurgie de la main et peut-être le
développement sur sur la france dans un
deuxième temps c'est ça peut être à mon
avis quelque chose de bénéfique pour
tous les patients en france
le merci d'être venu en parler
ce journal docteur françois bruchot
merci également à elisabeth calment
d'être d'avoir été présent sur ce
plateau la direction saint germain en
laye à présent la ville et l'université
de cergy-pontoise s'associent cette
semaine elles ont lancé au sein du
campus le campus x campus je vais y
arriver le campus académique x campus
c'est son nom au sein des locaux de
l'entreprise x blue les détails dans ce
sujet d'eléonore sinoquet cet acte et la
ville de saint germain en laye et six
mois et cergy paris université ont signé
une convention pour le lancement d'un
nouveau campus académique lundi 22 mars
il sera basé dans les locaux du campus
d'entreprise x bout je suis très content
parce que c'est l'une des ambitions que
l'on porte on est dans on est dans un
département allaient qui vieillit un
petit peu un sens l'injurier et d'avoir
voilà tout ce dynamisme toute cette
jeunesse qui va venir à terme saint
germain sera une ville avec peut-être
5000 étudiants
voilà on a déjà sciences po on a déjà
beaucoup d'enseignement supérieur et on
renforce notre ambition universitaire
avec cette nouvelle arrivée ce
partenariat privilégié avec l'université
de cergy pontoise
ce futur pôle universitaire
internationale sera tournée vers le
design et l'ingénierie à terme entre 500
et 600 étudiants y évolueront sur ce
campus
on va déjà avoir un open design lab
c'est à dire un espace ouvert aux
étudiants
de l'école de design de ses ouailles
tech mais aussi de sciences po mais
aussi de sup de vente et on va pouvoir y
venir développer ses idées prototype est
testé échanger créer ensemble le projet
démarré fin août 2001 n'a pas été
ralenti par la crise sanitaire les
futurs locaux sont actuellement en
travaux pour une rentrée des étudiants
prévue en septembre 2021 voilà pour ce
campus académique x campus ça y est j'ai
le nom ce jeudi saint quentin en
yvelines propose la deuxième édition de
son ide job dating a rendez vous
exclusivement réservé à l'alternance 55
entreprises seront présentes pour
proposer une centaine de contrats des
jeunes de 16 à 25 ans présentation dans
cette interview express collectées par
mélanie poker et ce job dating sera
entièrement en ligne
compte tenu du contexte sanitaire donc
ça va être effectivement un ide job
dating avec donc des inscriptions
préalables on s'inscrit sur le site ski
emploi.fr et on peut rentrer en contact
avec des entreprises présentent des
institutions présentes et on aura aussi
des webinaires une occasion pour ces
jeunes de se former en amont de
l'événement avec des petits ateliers qui
auront lieu en ligne et qui concerneront
la manière de rédiger son cv la manière
de passer son entretien
[Musique]
certains secteurs qui redémarre
c'est le cas du numérique ces cas de la
santé c'est le cas des services à la
personne
c'est le cas du bâtiment tout l'enjeu
c'est d'aider nos jeunes a quand même
s'en sortir en misant sur ces secteurs
qui redémarre telles que je les ai cité
et on a beaucoup de jeunes qui qui
subissent vraiment cette crise de
manière très très violente et donc il
faut les aider
[Musique]
c'est une manière pour le jeune de mêler
la théorie à la pratique
c'est une occasion pour lui de faire de
son alternance un tremplin vers l'emploi
un emploi durable et puis ça lui donne
une je dirais une carte en plus sur son
cv
et puis cette découverte pour le moins
insolite vendredi à gargenville deux
pitons dont l'un à mesurant 1 mètre 50
ont été trouvés dans un sac en pleine
rue c'est un cycliste qui a signalé ce
sac suspect qui bougeait sur le bas côté
de la route et les reptiles ont été
capturés par la brigade de secours
animalier des pompiers des yvelines
déshydraté en état d'hypothermie elle
les animaux sont sains et saufs une
enquête a été ouverte par la police
municipale de gargenville afin
d'identifier l'auteur de l'abandon voilà
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité dans un instant retrouver
un nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture
présentée par justine brasier très belle
soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]